good afternoon and welcome back to the
face of steel here in the former temple
borough steelworks in rotherham
we're here today for big ideas live a
new format for sky news in which we take
time to explore big issues and big ideas
if there is a big idea that the
government would like us to be thinking
about today it is leveling up
but as ian king pointed out in a session
this morning
what it means in practice is still to
become entirely clear
some of my own family who live in
sheffield
who
work in nottingham as well never tire of
telling me that there's a vast
deafening
sucking sound common across the north
and they say that's the sound of power
money and jobs being sucked from the
regions into london
well they love where they live and they
think they have a better environment
better
quality of life than in the over heated
south but every time something goes
wrong they tell me covid
fuel shortages uh the threat of
inflation or indeed stagflation we're
now talking about
they feel that they're going to be hit
first and hit harder
well yesterday the former deputy prime
minister michael hesseltein
speaking here on sky news offered his
own big idea to me and he said that the
government needed to devolve power to
accountable leaders named elected
leaders in the regions because they know
what's needed
so is that the answer or would that just
mean more fragmentation of the nation
can the identity and pride felt by many
communities
across the north of england helped to
drive economic growth
i'll be discussing that with a panel of
experts in a moment but first our
business correspondent helen and smith
is here
to set the scene
hello name thanks trevor and afternoon
again everyone so we've heard so much
about leveling up over the last year or
so haven't we not just from those who
propose it but also from those who
protest they don't really know what it
means and historically there's been a
lot written and a lot said about the
inequalities between north and south but
at this very moment that we're at now
post-pandemic what are the challenges
and the opportunities as well to getting
this country well and truly leveled so
first of all where are we at i want to
address head-on that notion that the
north routinely gets less spent on it
than the south is that true so take a
look at this firstly i want you to pay
attention only to how high up the blobs
are on this graph first uh what we've
charted along this axis here is the
total spend
per head in each region of the country
by the government in 2020 so total look
london up there at the top uh is the
most but look the northeast and the
northwest actually come in second and
third however total spend doesn't really
give us the whole picture because total
spend includes things like nhs salaries
and benefits and money that sort of is
there and then it's gone so what we've
plotted along at the axis at the bottom
is total investment spend
for each region of the country
investments been going into
infrastructure and things like that and
as you can see a slightly different
story again london out there at the the
far end southeast coming second but and
although the northwest not so bad the
northeast yorkshire and the humber much
further over towards here so a very
different story now crucially this is
just a moment in time this is just 2020
and of course what happens over time
incredibly important as well so what
we've charted here is the growth in
investment spend since 2016. 2016 of
course you remember just shortly after
we very first heard about the northern
powerhouse actually you can see up in
the top there the green line is the west
midlands that has had its spend grow the
most in terms of investment that's
likely a lot to do with hs2 but the
south is coming in second there and
crucially i just want to draw your
attention to the yellow line at the
bottom yorkshire and the humber where we
currently are really one of the only
regions in the country where spend
really declined over that period peaking
just about to what it was in 2016 very
very recently there now look in terms of
regional recovery and regional
prosperity it's not just what the
government is doing that matters but
it's also what we as consumers are doing
and how we're behaving so what we've
charted here is footfall
footfall recovery in cities around the
country since the pandemic compared to
pre-pandemic levels for obvious reasons
we haven't been able to put every single
one on there could be a lot but i've
just picked out a few that i think tell
interesting stories firstly the two at
the top blackpool south end it's worth
saying there are only four cities in
four cities and towns in the whole
country where footfall is now recovered
to what it was before the pandemic or
indeed exceeding it they're all seaside
and touristy towns down at the bottom
there london sheffield that big story of
city centres just really struggling to
recover in terms of their footfall and
then in the orange barnsley we've put
that on there because there's a really
interesting story around some of these
sort of smaller regional residential
towns actually some that historically
have been a little more deprived some of
the football and the spenders recovered
much much better there than in other
places that's partly uh because of it's
more it's more residential people live
there and also because a lot of the
businesses in those places are more
likely to be essential so people need to
get back there for their essentials
spent
it matters as well what business is
doing of course the number of companies
the number of jobs the amount of
employment what we've shown you here is
the growth in the number of companies in
each region of the country since 2010 so
since that financial crisis and look
it's really clear isn't it london the
south east the south west it is uh still
those regions that have by far the
biggest growth in the number of
companies and we know that there's
well-documented problems with qualified
people sometimes choosing to leave to
travel south particularly to the capital
for work and very finely i want to leave
you with this this is incidentally my
favorite chart of the day and i think it
gives a slightly quirky look into some
of the problems we face this shows the
inequality of broadband connectivity in
different countries across the world so
the red blobs the least connected region
in each country the green blobs the most
connected region in each country
essentially what this is showing us is
that we have a greater inequality of
connectivity in this country than
colombia has certainly a greater
inequality of connectivity than denmark
has and look our worst connected region
the northeast there is by far worse off
than the vast majority of all these
other countries the us france spain
worth saying the same picture plays out
when you look at germany italy portugal
so i hope this gives a bit of a sense of
just how much there is to do and just
how multi-faceted the problems are if we
really want to get this country well and
truly leveled up thank you trevor hello
nan thank you very much indeed
some striking grasp there i'm i'm i'm
mildly disturbed by the the uh idea that
it's easier to watch us in colombia than
it is uh in gateshead uh right now um
but let's uh come actually we'll come to
the son of gateshead in a moment because
i'm joined by a
group of experts
who are going to discuss what the north
needs from government and what indeed
the north might do for itself today uh
chris greene is the conservative mp for
bolton west and atherton
simon rush is the founder of northern
power women and northern power futures
charles edward is the vice chancellor of
leeds trinity university
and sebastian payne the aforesaid son of
gateshead is the author of broken
heartland a journey through labour's
lost england just out this week well
let's let's start by looking
forward let's let's talk about
opportunities they say we should never
let a crisis go to waste
at conway this morning identified four
crises that we're in the middle of labor
uh distribution materials and so on
simon is there an opportunity for the
north in this crisis um i think we're
always going to look at an opportunity
when we set out
at the start of the pandemic is what can
we do and i think our focus has always
been about what can we do we know
there's lots of barriers there we know
there's lots of inequality we know
there's lots of hurdles but from the the
campaign and the movement that i created
which is about accelerating gender
equality and social mobility from the
north it's very much looking about that
we can approach and so at the start of
the pandemic like what can we do what
can we do the first thing was to check
in on people was to check in how are we
going to wrap an arm around these senior
business leaders doing amazing making
these you know um
history-making uh decisions every day
and also to checking on those at the
start of their career who think actually
what an earth is ahead of me how on
earth are we going to navigate what's
ahead so what we did when we set out um
at the start of this is we we documented
as we went along and a year ago we we
created a leveling up report but it was
our level leveling up by powering on be
i'm very much about looking at the
opportunities as you say trevor and the
the positive thing that came out and
looking at the some of the good stuff
that happened and i think that's what we
have to do at times because there's
certain things that we can't do but
actually what can we do and i think that
there's a company one of the reports
recently is one of our northern powerman
community a company in leeds just not
too far up the way has had a 30 growth
it's a small uh pal intelligence uh
software development company but they
have 30 growth and they've done that
because of the lack of geographical
barriers and the lack and the imp
impetus around flexible work which we
haven't had before okay charles um
you're in if you like the intellectual
industry do you think uh that what we're
seeing as someone's saying is a
situation in which
there's a new opportunity created by
in a way destruction of geography
there will always be opportunities uh i
think the question is providing the
appropriate and conducive environment to
be able to harness those opportunities
if i give you an example from the league
city region where
i reside at the moment we have 380
000 people or 26 percent of the adult
population that have no qualifications
or very low skills there must be
something in in that resource pool which
we call the uh
tapping
if you look at how the world is changing
around us and you look at what we need
to do around
the construction industry to help us
with the issue of sustainability
especially in our homes
there's the suggestion that 70 percent
of all the houses we need for the next
30 years have been built already it's
what do we do to convert and modernize
them to make sure they are habitable and
meet the energy use so there's something
to be done
around that there's something to be done
around the transportation uh as part of
supporting us in reaching
um the carbon neutrality but i think we
need to ask ourselves the question
in the policy we put forward
in the legislation and regulation
how do we create an environment for
businesses for the young people give
them the confidence to think about
tomorrow and then the future so there is
opportunities but we have to harness
that very very uh quietly and
confidently chris green um well we've
heard two examples of of opportunities
can um
can the north realize those
opportunities on its own
or does it need something from the wider
nation and from government well um the
north is part of the united kingdom so
it's got to be a joint effort i'm
looking forward to later this year for
the government to produce its white
paper on leveling up we have a strong
sense of what it ought to mean
lisa many commentators and people
looking in have a strong sense of what
it ought to be and i think a key aspect
is when we look at the city of london
and the wider south east what's one of
its great qualities transport if someone
wants to locate a business in the
southeast of england you know your pool
of talent is immense
we need the north of england to have
that pool of talent and how do we get
that pool of talent for any business
wanting to locate here it's by having
far better network
communications whether it's public
transport or motorways and railways we
need to sort these things out but the
second point is uh focused on education
it needs to go hand in hand with
transport infrastructure there was a
report from the children's commissioner
about three years ago growing up north
and it showed london uh which
in 2004 was way behind the north of
england now is way ahead of the north of
england we've got to have that focus in
the north of england on education if we
get these things at the same time the
talent we create in the north will get
jobs in the north and we create our own
prosperity and actually we choose what
businesses what industries we want to
champion
but better transport and better
education are
desirable everywhere aren't there i mean
is there anything special about what one
would do in the north well it's basic
things so on the one hand we uh
are talking great deal at the moment
with hs2
and you look at hs2 which is
fundamentally about a road link to
london
and it's very different linked to london
sorry a rail link yes a rail link
to london and you look at people getting
the railways between manchester and
liverpool it's very difficult they're
only 30 35 miles apart it's very
difficult at the moment and we need that
um
northern power rail a proper vision for
what that's going to be and when that's
going to be delivered some businesses
know this is the time to invest and we
really get motoring or on the track
sebastian payne you've been um
conducting or doing a tour of northern
cities um in your own
rather exotic mode of transport you can
tell us about um
how are you seeing it do you think
that we're in a situation where there
could be a renaissance uh of
of the north and if so what would it
look like
well it's very interesting we're talking
about this here because i'm sitting and
you can see on a steel beam directly up
there it says labor support strikes vote
scar girl so i think that is a slogan
from a slightly different political age
in this building probably not the place
to start no
the remnants but i think this is
actually an example of how the north has
changed in a way many people haven't
quite recognized it because when people
have looked at many parts of the country
that voted for brexit and voted for
conservative for the first time in 2019
that's the either they think of they
think of an industrial era that's in
decline not places that have gone
through a lot of change and a lot of
renewal since de-industrialization and
one the place i visited in broken heart
lands is concert again a great steel
town in the northeast of england that
edits prime employed 6 000 steel workers
that closed in 1980 unemployment hit 36
percent at its peak and that went
through a lot of pain but if you look
where it is now it's got many new
businesses private housing and crucially
a more diversified economic base so in
some ways there's many things to be
hopeful about that these police are not
stuck in the past in my view they're not
looking backwards they are optimistic
about the future but to come some of the
points that chris was making there is a
long term under investment particularly
on transport particularly on
infrastructure so that's why i think it
deserves particular focus from this
government there but i think it's not
just about money though it is about
structural reform and this is when lord
michael hesselton is completely right on
mayors and power that you're not going
to make these places better from
whitehall it has to be done with good
strong local leaders so if you look in
south yorkshire you've had dan jarvis or
van gaal in the teas valley they have
bought enacted change so we need more
mayors with more powers we need to make
up for that historic under investment
transport and skills as well is
completely crucial in some ways the
solution is not that difficult to make
the north better the key thing is
delivery and doing it and making it
happen
just i'm going to come to some question
uh comment i think we've got from the
audience before i do that
charles this is your skills um ed conway
in a
blizzard of in interesting charts today
one of the ones that was i thought most
significant was that he showed that
every country has a skills mismatch that
is to say if you ask people
have you got the skills to do the thing
that the job you're currently doing um
in germany about 20
are essentially in the wrong job
in this country it's more like 40
percent
do you think that there is an issue with
our capability
of
of getting the right people to be able
to do the right job to
to essentially rebound from where we've
been in the last 18 months two years
it's interesting trevor the the issue is
both skill shortages and skills gap i
think the point you were making natalie
was the skills gap
in other words
those who
required particular set of skills for
the jobs they need that quality of skill
is not there i have to say the issue
have been going on well before brexit
well before our covet it's just got
slightly worse
i remember many many years ago when i
was a student
of construction about 30 years ago and i
know you do have what is called direct
labor supply
where
a particular company trains up their own
staff
and not a wait to get the staff from
supply chains but those areas are gone i
think it's a mixture of us having
policies that are consistent and
sustained we've had deterring and
throwing where the government at times
is finger pointed asking you haven't
invested and the employer turned around
to say
we can't invest because the environment
is not conducive so the issue issue
becomes we all need to know that this is
joined up the employer has a role to
play the government has the role to play
now they say the university which i'm
part of has a role to play to make sure
we look at skills for today and skills
for tomorrow we're going to come back to
this issue of coordination let me go to
hashem in our audience
um hashim i think you had a comment on
this issue yeah so i want to say it's
been reported recently that the
disparity in productivity
and economic output per capita between
parts of the north and the southeast is
in relative terms as large as it was
between east germany and west germany
before reunification it took decades and
trillions to narrow that gap so i think
that demonstrates that leveling up must
go beyond electoral cycles it's not just
about the amount of money that we spend
but importantly about where we spend it
and crucially it can't be achieved by
central government alone so i wanted to
ask what can be done to create an
environment which attracts more private
sector investment and what role does uh
ambitious regional mayors that you
mentioned sebastian play in supporting
that well actually um
let's do let's make that
almost literally concrete take a case in
point which is transport andrew
mcphillips i think has a question on
exactly that
uh that issue andrew
yeah thanks um new research published by
mcdonald today shows that northern
powerhouse rail could have a greater
economic impact than the government's
own figures even suggest
does the panel agree that a new line
linking the cities of the north and
which is also reliant on hs2 being
delivered in full
is a project which if cancelled leaves
leveling up as nothing more than a
broken promise you're addressing this a
moment ago chris uh do you agree that
scrapping it would be a broken promise
and
tie that if you would to hachim's point
about how we actually
coordinate how we make thing bring this
all together
rather being a series of projects i
think we have ought to be cautious about
bringing it together too much because
you have to leave that opportunity and
perspective from the private sector to
think these are the opportunities we
have i do think to a significant extent
uh that the north of england when you're
looking at globalization when you're
looking at other specialties in the
united kingdom you look at the golden
triangle you look at the
uh financial specialization in london
you look you look at different parts of
the country i do believe that north of
england uh and manufacturing do go
together uh very well so the government
has to set a vision that enables
manufacturing you've got to have better
transport obviously
hs2 is often seen as a route down to
london and one of the disappointing
facts was that
northern power rail
was dependent upon hs2 being completed
for the railway stations whether it's in
leeds or in manchester to cut across so
we have to find out very quickly i think
to give people confidence what's going
to happen uh with that eastern leg up to
leeds on hs2 and if that does go that
there is a railway station uh that's
going to be put in place for northern
power rail which needs to be get going
uh very soon so there's a
huge what what is mr the secretary of
transport saying saying to you uh the
minister responsible for the northern
powerhouse as well uh so at the moment
um i i think they're looking up uh
looking forward to the publication of
the
uh leveling up white paper i think
there's a lot of stuff to come from uh
michael gove as well who's just been
appointed and responsible for devolution
as well so i think there's a great deal
of work and ultimately uh the person we
need to be focused on uh is uh the
chancellor at the spending review and
the budget later this month where these
announcements ought to be made so it all
comes down to rishi it does
simmer i think collaboration is key
you've talked about the the roles that
the mayors have to play and i've seen
there's clearly a connectivity between
andy burnham and steven they will
naturally play nice but i've seen that
cross mare collaboration and coming
together and there's been just recently
only a couple of weeks ago there's been
the new pandemic institute that was
launched in liverpool and that was done
almost through a series of bringing
together almost the impossible how do
you bring academia how do you bring
healthcare how do you bring government
how do you bring um global investor into
a city to create jobs to create this you
know so i think there's examples there
but i think there's there's elements of
have to collaborate i have to play nice
and i think when it comes to some of
that
those big decisions as well it's having
the right people at the table we've
talked about skills we've talked about
skills all day where are those those
decisions that are being made about
those
whether it be young people whether it be
people underrepresented communities need
to be at the table when we're actually
allocating or making these decisions as
well is key before we leave the topic of
rail um i i don't want uh you know the
soft sudden i don't want anybody to to
leave this thinking that the north is
just a place where everybody is exactly
the same i suspect that there are people
who think that there are
imbalances here alison matthews i think
has a point on this in relation to
transport alison
i think we're going to get a microphone
to you and it's with you now
hey yeah so i was just seeing um that
the north isn't manchester and liverpool
if you kind of guess by me accent i'm
not far from concert woohoo
and and i feel like durham and newcastle
really get forgotten about and it's not
just when it comes to transport it's a
lot of things when you talk about the
north when government talk about the
north tends to be manchester liverpool
leads and the north east really does get
forgotten about are we going to get
included in things
um
seb i i talked to
your king the king of the north um andy
burnham uh ten days ago and uh i he he
has he wants transport links and so on
and uh he was
quite cross at the suggestion that what
what he's putting forward
would benefit
central manchester or indeed central
leads do you think though that there is
an issue
about
how you construct
change and particularly how to construct
a transport network
that might end up with some bits of the
north doing well
but the bits of the north that really
need help
being
where they've always been
at the back of the queue i think this is
the key thing about northern powerhouse
rail that chris was talking about and if
you look at the lens if this is a new
railway between liverpool and leeds then
if you live in dublin more concert then
you're going to say well how does this
actually help me but of course by
building that there are many other
places along the way and that's why
we'll have to see what's in the northern
powerhouse rail plan before we can see
what it's going to do there but to take
the example of high speed 2 railway
which i think will still happen in some
form you create that for the new
intercity links but the other the
existing west coast mainline is there
and is freed up to allow much greater
links to milton keynes to crew to many
of the other small places that often
don't get forgotten on the way so i
think you can do both in this but i
think there is a really crucial identity
question we mentioned the northeast here
and you know there is a north of time
melody at the moment which to me is
completely mad when there is a clear
economic unit in tyneside that includes
newcastle gatesair dumpster and what
have you you could create conurbation
around that why does that not exist
because all the local council leaders
were arguing and they wouldn't do a deal
with each other so sometimes problems of
these things are founded locally due to
local rivals due to people's feelings
about each other if you don't mind me
trevor to come back on the point that
was made earlier about
business investment i think that is
actually very key here because yes you
can pull money into transport yes you
can make up for decades of under
investment but to get a sustainable
economy in the places that have
struggled you've got to make an
appetizing business environments and i
think there's obviously the government
are looking at free ports you've got
questions about enterprise zones things
you can do to encourage business
investments so when that white paper
comes out later this month that's
actually what i'm most interested in
because it's easy to pour money into
things but you can only do that so many
times and that doesn't create a
sustainable economic base when you hit
the next downturn and public spending
eventually gets cut back and if you look
at the example of liverpool when it was
regenerated um in the 1980s and 1990s
that was based on public private
partnerships i think that has to be
really key to this if you're going to
make it not just a one-off hit
um jackie freeborn i think has raised
this point about public uh
public-private partnerships and to the
extent to which they are important i
wonder if we could come to jackie in a
moment um
ah there you are
uh we will get a microphone to you now
jackie oh hi hi um yeah my question is
exactly about that because i think we've
seen some great examples of where public
and private have come together to solve
problems but it doesn't work all the
time and i'm just wondering whether we
need some sort of institute of
enlightened leadership and collaboration
so we can learn from those best examples
and put it into practice at a local
level local politics always get in the
way always do it's just the nature of it
is but businesses and public sector are
very different in the way that they make
decisions the way that they have to be
accountable and i'm just wondering how
do we capture the best of that and roll
it out to places and make sure it
becomes an intricate part of the economy
and what we do to actually regenerate
places
charles you you run a big public sector
outfit at a university and um
you presumably sit at the center of
a kind of collaboration um how does it
work and does it work actually in leeds
that's that's a very very good question
and a good question from jackie
i had a university like trinity
university we work with over 3 000
businesses
and we take pride in in saying that all
our students at the undergraduate
program
have placement the only university that
will say that all are undergraduate and
we're able to do that because of the
collaboration and the cooperation we
have with businesses just last week i
was in a meeting with the chambers of
commerce
speaking to businesses wanting to know
how
we can co-jointly
offer our programs to our students to
make sure that these students are
undergoing a program so that when they
finish they're as ready as they can with
businesses so partnership collaboration
i think it's important and i have to say
there are increasing opportunities to do
that apprenticeship it's one way
we take pride as a university to have
apprenticeship with the west yorkshire
police
and with the prison services the unlock
program and we cannot do that without
having real partnership but it's
partnership where the two
partners will have to get something and
put something uh in that i don't think
we will get real leveling up if we don't
partner and making sure that there is
trust honesty
and reciprocity in the way we partner so
it's working if it's put together well
simon do you think um that we've got the
environment that allows that kind of
partnership one of the things that
businesses say and this is they say that
all say this all over the country not
just in the north that for example the
apprenticeship program
too difficult to bureaucratic and in
fact i think that there are several
hundred million
quids worth of um
grant
sitting unused because employers
can't be bothered to go through
the all of the processes and the hoops
well it's interesting actually there's a
study out from newcastle university at
newcastle college story earlier this
year which stated that um
now more than ever there's more more
places um people are looking to work and
study locally because they don't want to
be in a situation where they're having
to be away from home if a another uh
situation like the last 18 months arises
and i think the the rise in searches for
higher uh higher level apprenticeship
was certainly to 171 percent or
something like that
so i think that demand proves that
there's got to be a simple
simplification but that that's the
challenge that happens is those
decisions and how it's all made and the
route to getting it is made with you
know by the same people making the same
decisions that's why you need to bring
those people who are trying to access
this whether it be the students whether
the businesses got to bring people
together and it comes back to that
conversation again about let's bring
different people into the mix to ensure
that these things
thrive there's no point having these
opportunities out there then people
there's a demand for them 171 people
searching for those higher level
apprentices but they can't get to it so
we have to change we have to fix the
system by bringing the right people to
discuss what do we need to make it
easier for people to do crack on and and
get engaged with them uh chris uh
is there a problem here the government
talks a good game about doing all of
this kind of thing and by the way this
is government of all stamps but on to
take the example of the apprenticeships
actually one of the things that became
clear quite early in the apprenticeship
program is that it worked at high level
so uh for example the the showcase
example for the apprenticeship program
is uh rolls-royce and derby fantastic
but that's basically degree level but
actually lower down
or at lower levels of qualification
it doesn't seem to work or the the cost
in resource and difficulty getting it to
happen it's so great it's not worth it
for employers
well it's uh it's very difficult uh for
many organizations to make the
apprenticeship levy work corporations
can because basically organizations like
uh rolls royce other large organizations
are basically doing uh this
apprenticeship approach already all they
have to do is configure what they're
already doing
uh into a format where they can draw
that money back into their organization
smaller organizations find it far more
difficult the company in my constituency
still works
they train their people they train their
people for decades
and it doesn't work for them and so
therefore they don't feel it's an
apprenticeship levy for reinvestment
they feel it's a tax
and the government has to be far more
respectful of organizations at whatever
level and rather than having a
an ambition which from the outside
objectively you just think this is about
a large number of apprenticeships so a
minister can say we have achieved x y or
zed it's got to be far more respectful
of different size organizations and yes
if we want to encourage larger
organizations to invest in
apprenticeships that's fine but we've
got to appreciate that they're largely
already doing it okay
we've got a question from
bob jeffrey who i think is represents
the sheffield trade
sheffield trade council which if i have
my history right it's one of the uh
kind of fundamental organizations of the
of the trade union movement producing i
think people like david blanket if i'm
not mistaken bob second oldest in the
country after aberdeen um so yeah we
at sheffield tuc we set up a campaign in
2016 called sheffield needs pay rise
this was in response to a resolution
foundation report that showed the
sheffield city region had the highest
proportion of workers on low pay of any
city region in the uk
now associated with that we've seen very
high levels of underemployment lots of
people in zero hour contracts and part
of what our campaign is doing is trying
to fight to get better work uh terms and
conditions for workers so that
businesses particularly large businesses
aren't just taking money out of the
community while in disproportionately
employing staff on precarious contracts
now while we're coming at that from a
trade union angle there's increasing
talk of good work charters in city
regions as a mechanism to to drive up
terms and conditions and i wondered what
the panel thought of those initiatives
um so payne you you probably can't move
in westminster which is your
where you normally work for some for
people going high wage high skill low
immigration let's leave the low
immigration for a moment i want to come
to that um
what can we do about the the low wage
problem that bob's talking about
well this is not something new we should
say by the way that this issue about
wages and skills we've been trying to
fix in this country pretty much ever
since the second world war and we've
tried various schemes of just putting
more money in without the productivity
gains and we saw inflation that resulted
from that we've tried various skills and
apprenticeships i think we are on a much
better track now than we have been ever
ever before about that and look the
johnson government is having a very good
push at this by keeping those migration
levels low and hoping that that will
naturally result in the labor market
increasing wages and that does seem to
be happening whether that's happening at
a sustainable rate that's going to not
without big economic bubbles in the
coming months is yet to be seen there
but i think fundamentally it's that site
you were talking about earlier trevor in
terms of the gal people in the right
jobs and the heat between moving between
you know where we were and where we're
heading i think when you look at the
kona virus pandemic it has exposed so
much of stuff that was already there but
below the service many zombie companies
that were based on you know very cheap
labor very low skilled labor and very
tight profit margins they've been wiped
out by the pandemic and i don't think
anyone fully knows the answer to this
because what we're trying to do in this
country i don't think has ever been done
in such a short space of time so quickly
you know if boyce johnson said i wanted
to do this in 18 months you could see a
way of going towards that and that could
be a gradual process unless they
pull back on not um allowing more
skilled people in through the visas
program then we're going to try and do
this for a very short quick period of
time and i think we eventually see how
the public feels about this because we
can see the disruptions in hdv drivers
in terms of co2 and food production they
will eventually ease because the labor
market will kill out and they will get
higher wages but the disruption to get
there is going to be really quite
significant so it's like a shortcut to
try and do something we've been trying
to do for decades
so on
when we think about uh in
the industrial north and wages and all
the rest of it i think that the image
that comes to mind is usually
blokes in overalls in places like this
but actually low wages
are more characteristically
uh
associated with female employment and to
some extent public service employment
can we actually do anything about that
without
the the kinds of consequences that seb's
talking about which is we throw money at
it inflation rages and then we go back
to square one i think we're at a sliding
doors moment i think what um we've seen
in the last 18 months is flexibility
flexibility that has never been afforded
to particularly those who are in low
paid um and also in those caregiving
roles as well you know the the amount of
money it's billions of pounds on the
economy that is that unpaid work economy
but that opportunity that has that
should not i don't subscribe to build
but better i subscribe to build forward
better because i think you know it's not
about just taking or we'll just go back
to the way it was i think it is a
sliding doors and i think we have to
take the opportunities around this
flexibility because otherwise we're
going to see um we're going to revert
back to like in 1950s britain if we're
not careful if so if the if we've got
organizations going to change away or we
can't do with that anymore you've all
got to be in the office we can't do this
we don't know what's around the corner i
think it's a i think someone i was
talking to last week was like you know
this is the worst worst time to be
making a big decision at the moment
because we don't know quite where we are
so i think we have to be careful that we
don't
we want to go forward better but we are
a slide indoors we cannot go back to
women at home and and the low pay jobs
and you know
going into those very very sort of very
stereotypical offices we have to take
the opportunities and this is where the
forward thinking employers and small
businesses can set that culture and
there's a study by uh student young
earlier this year that you know um half
of people would leave their jobs um if
if it wasn't a purpose-led um
you know employer if they didn't have
that opportunity and i think were
flexibility it was always it was always
a wage and salary expectations purpose
is now more important
for those people on that career track
chris um
the
you know the prime minister
who's cheerful sort of bloke
constantly holds out the sunlit upland
high wage high skills better better all
that um
but as seven saying
it's not a
nice straight gradient from here to
there
and we might find ourselves in a place
where
actually what we have is
um
a very tricky labor market not rising
wages
this could be a political catastrophe
for the con for the government couldn't
it
well we're in a very difficult situation
the pandemic has had a massive impact
and we can't take that out of the
equation so how do we uh get our
recovery going the more we impose upon
business and i'm sure this won't be uh
what gentlemen would like to hear the
more we impose upon business the more
challenges they will face
in trying to create that business and if
we remove competitive advantage from
certain areas you won't get that
business in the first place and what we
need to see businesses locating in
sheffield in uh many northern towns and
cities
and build upon that because it's going
to take years for improvements in
education improvements and transport
improvements in other areas of our lives
when we're trying to recover and level
up it's gonna take a very long time but
we need to get the jobs now in the
coming
days weeks and months so imposing and
how does that happen
uh
with the spending review i want to see
some pretty positive and with the budget
uh a pretty positive ambition i want to
see uh clear details in the white paper
for leveling up setting out exactly what
we're going to do how we're going to do
it and we might be talking about brexit
at some point but one of the aspects of
uh brexit is
how do we
be more flexible in our interpretation
and use of um
laws that impact business so for for
example the
uh agritech business is pretty much dead
in europe it's booming in america it's
booming in other places now that with
outside the uh european union how much
can we focus on agritech biotech other
businesses and industries which are
coming down the line which are here
already that we can use a competitive
advantage let me ask a couple questions
you you said so there's something i just
wanted to quickly come back on that if
you don't mind which is that technology
is very crucial to all this as well that
many industries you mentioned
agriculture all going through a great
wave of automation that is going to be
key but i don't think you can rely on
that to make up for the gaps within the
labour market you've got to be very
careful about this that technology is
coming you need to be ready and to adapt
to it and to get crucially those
productivity gains you don't
automatically get with higher wages but
you can't wholly rely on it that in fact
is exactly the point i wanted to come to
there is a labor market problem isn't
there that we aren't necessarily
uh we don't necessarily have
the right
people with the right skills in the
right place
what would you say uh if one of the
things that regions could control as
they do for example in canada
uh is immigration
canadian provinces
have a certain number of visas which
they are allowed to issue because to
meet their needs now
would there be any mileage at all in
the north or parts of north being able
to seek out the right talents wherever
they happen to be in the world what do
you think so i think the idea you could
allow certain regions to have visa
schemes i think is one that is
definitely worth examining because if
you want to create those clusters of
industry where you're attracting talent
from across the world and being
particularly appetizing so everyone
doesn't just go into the london
southeast bucket which is what's
happened for much skilled migration i
think over recent decades that's
definitely worth exploring but of course
as well you get many practical
situations about that in terms of how
you implement it how that feeds into the
whole uk's migration policy too now of
course the danger of going down that
route is you do end up with a wholly
planned economy which will go and say
this is going to happen here we're going
to have this many people and i think you
know we've tried to plan the economy in
various times of our recent history and
it hasn't always been wholly successful
but i think the crucial point which
you're right trevor is you've got to
have the ability for each region to do
things differently and to have the
powers to do that so whether it's
getting more visas for a particular
aspect of their labor markets to having
control over taxes being able to maybe
do something around corporation tax or
business rates within different areas
because
that's the only way you break this cycle
that we've had and i think there was a
change where there's a very technical
thing it's a very important thing the
treasury has this thing called the green
book which defines where government
investment goes and rishi sunak ripped
up the green book and rewrote it last
year that was one most important things
because that's become the cyclical thing
which is where do you want to invest
where you're going to get the highest
rate of return where is that london the
southeast and that's how you've got the
situation of the overheated economy
within the south and that's now been
redone to put an
um an influence on other aspects not
just your direct financial return of
investment so that's the kind of thing i
think you need to look up but i think
definitely visas for particular regions
i think that's that's something that the
men should definitely lobby for charles
what do you think uh leads being able to
control its labor market
i think there's so much to be said uh
around
the point sev has made
one thing is clear the regions the
cities the towns and the businesses in
those localities are best able to
identify the skills they need
they're also able to identify the
matching of skills to jobs whether it's
high skills and low skills i'd wanted to
intervene in the last question about the
low skills and and the lower jobs and
why we are where we are very very um
complicated and complex but nonetheless
i think there's something to be said
about giving
a kind of real autonomy to the regions
to decide what they want for their
businesses for the individuals for the
regions and the cities but i think
there's complication around
managing the wider concept
administratively and logistically
um the issue of immigration and we need
to handle that with care
but i think there's also got to be that
cross-regional collaboration as well
because otherwise you're reinventing
wheels so i think it's the power in that
coming together
um
we've heard mentioned several times in
this discussion the leveling up white
paper uh for which
you know there are millions sitting
waiting uh rather like you know waiting
for the new harry potter or whatever it
is um
i'm going to ask each one of you to tell
me
something that you really want to see in
that white paper you know whether it is
a number
of money or it is a sentence or it is a
policy hesseltine saying
you know uh have accountable leaders in
every place and that would be the thing
that made difference so each one of you
start with you chris
if you if if the prime minister rang me
up and said chris you've got a paragraph
and
you can write it and nobody can
interfere with it what would it be
what i would have is a commitment to
nuclear energy we need reliable
cheap energy the northwest of england
has a huge nuclear sector huge amounts
of talent in northwest of england so i
want to see that because i believe the
north of england and parliament leveling
a significant part of our leveling up
ought to be manufacturing including
heavy manufacturing
and therefore we need reliable energy
that doesn't go out every time the wind
stops blowing so nuclear energy it's
good for industry and it's going to be
good for the north
in our young west investment in uh
ensuring that they
we can
trump all form of fear that young people
have right now about what their future
is and makes that they can thrive and
grow their career in the north and seats
at the table for
female female-led businesses black asian
minority-led businesses and young people
when these big decisions are being made
and a i can give you the bank details
for a bank account for that to be paid
into
[Laughter]
yeah well um
you can find that on the website
okay charles trevor you'll expect me to
say real investment in skills and jobs
and in the potential of the young ones
and i think the university sector the
higher education sector and the further
education sector really really play a
role in trying to build this skilled
base that the smas and large
organizations need
research and development there needs to
be funding in that and i think they need
to be funding in the relationship
between businesses and the academic
sector so
i want to see a very clear plan of
delivery about how all these changes are
going to be made because it's so easy
for politicians to talk about improving
life chances improving town centers
improving infrastructure but what we are
talking about is hundreds if not
thousands of tiny projects all across
the country which on the whole will
level up and i think essentially you
need to see a way to actually do that
because for me to successfully level up
is as big of a challenge to the british
state as brexit and we know that took a
long time and a lot of effort so i want
clear detail plan and accountability
data metrics what does success look like
okay we've got a
couple of minutes and i just want to um
ask just a question of my own one of the
things that um i'm very struck by and
seb's book really
um without wanting to plug it uh
illustrates this rather brilliantly
um the big change that's come come about
has been in what you might call company
towns i i started life as a chemist and
they might have sent me to middlesbrough
and so on and but you know these are
towns which are built on a single
industry obviously it's sometimes in a
single
company and to some extent all that's
been destroyed and i just want to give
each one of you quickly 10 seconds
what do we do about towns which have
lost their original purpose i mean
it's a cultural thing as well said
when i went to wakefield which i think
is a very key example of one of those
places which was a male and mining place
it's found a new cultural identity
through art and culture through the
hepworth gallery the yorkshire sculpture
park and all different towns i think are
quite good at doing that but you've got
to have good transport links they can
get and link into those nearby other
towns and other cities as well because i
think if they're just left on their own
without the ability to have links to
their nearby region then they will feel
a bit down i can only have one on
quickly i think it's about learning from
other other cities or the other
communities that are built forward
better and involve the community in
their decision making
okay sorry charles sorry chris
but that's it for this discussion part
of our big ideas live on sky news uh in
a moment here in rotherham uh i'll be
sitting with
my colleagues from sky news to assess
what we've learned today ed conway ian
king and samantha washington and you can
follow that by going to the stream on
sky's website but for now
goodbye